Instructor: In
JavaScript, when you want to put
a variable inside of a string,
it's actually a pain in the ass
because you have to stop your
string, concatenate on the
variable, and then open your
string again and keep going.
Every other language has the
ability to just drop your
variables right inside of a
string and just interpolate it
like that, but not JavaScript.
What ends up happening is you
forget one of your closing, and
you get an error and it tells
you it's on line 11. You're like "
Of course it's on line 11, but I
don't know where it is." We
can fix all of that with what's
called template strings, or
template literals. In JavaScript
we have double quotes and single
quotes to make a string. Now we
have a third way to make a
string, and that is with back-
ticks. We're going to take
this code right here, and first
of all I'm going to make all
those const, as they do not
change, so there's no need to
have those as a var or a let.
Now we have a name variable,
we're setting that to "Snickers."
We have an age variable that's
set to two, and we have the
sentence variable that I'm
making. How do we change this
now? Let's look at it. I'm going
to actually use back-ticks here,
close the back-tick there, and
then anywhere I needed to open
that, we simply use dollar sign,
curly bracket -- you see the
syntax highlighting change --
and close your curly bracket.
That is going to pop in, or
interpolate, the actual variable
that we previously had set there.
We don't need any of this. We
want age, dollar sign
parentheses. You can also do
JavaScript straight away inside
of these curly brackets here.
You can pop in a variable, you
can run a function, you can also
run straight JavaScript. I'm
calculating the age in dog years
right inside of that, get rid of
that and we're good to go.
Console log sentence, and you
will now see it's just a regular
sentence. Uh oh, what
happened here? Const. I was
duplicating it so I could show
you the old version and the new
version. Obviously you can't
declare the same variable twice,
so I need to get rid of that.
Now it says my dog Snickers is
14 years old in dog years.
That is template strings at the
very basic. However there's
quite a bit more that we can do
with it. It can be very handy
other than just being able to
stick variables inside of it.